there are more Palestinian protests in  the West Bank this morning demonstrators  have been marching and some have lit  tires on fire CBS Evening News anchor  Jeff Glor is near Ramallah in the West  Bank close to the Israeli border Jeff  filed this report showing Israeli  soldiers firing tear gas and rubber  bullets at oncoming Palestinian  protesters you see the Israelis now  charging forward as health cities throw  rocks at them they've been firing tear  gas at times also rubber bullets to try  to push Palestinians back back into  where Ramallah is where the bigger crowd  is coming from this has been a  back-and-forth that we've been watching  [Music]  Israelis firing back right and now  - Jeff and his team are okay they just  had to put their gas masks on and to set  down the cameras just gonna have much  more on those protests tonight when he  anchors the CBS Evening News from  Jerusalem